[Music]
[Applause]
i believe guy fieri is a raiders fan
not sure if he'll be there for the
opener of that new stadium in vegas and
guy fieri the celebrity chef
host of diners drive-ins and dives and a
million other shows joining us on the
program
guy are you going to be there for the
raiders home opener
in vegas i'm going to tell you what
you're going to have to pry me away from
that place i opened a restaurant there
while we
we built a restaurant inside of the
stadium we were so excited to open
and uh you know guy fitty's tailgate and
unfortunately
um you know we didn't have the exact
season we wanted so
yeah we're gonna be there you know my
kid went to unlv i went to unlv so we're
we're both proud to be uh you know vegas
raiders all of it
is vegas a good food town
i'll tell you dp back in the day when i
went to college there it was who made
the best buffet you know it was like
buffets would go crazy sometimes there
were big numbers
and you couldn't find a great restaurant
at all and now
i think i think vegas is a food
destination i mean i think people go for
gaming still and they go for concerts
but really one of the epicenter one of
the main focuses
about vegas is the food and beverage
program
if i gave you a sneaky pick
statewide or city wise for great food if
i gave you a pic
yeah i'm going to give you a pic like a
smaller town city
where you go man that per capita
that one is off the chain as you might
say
wow i really like how you throw that
around uh okay
it's a big city it's a big little city i
always say chicago
chicago is one of my all-time faves
um it just has so much culture it has
it's so diverse it's old you know it's
an old city
um not as recognized i think as new york
and l.a
and so but i gotta tell you something
talk about amazing food
i was however just in houston the other
day i went down there and i was hanging
out with uh with my buddy bag
bag jeff bagwell and uh he's what a
character
you know him and we were down there and
we hit i'm telling you that houston
scene
is blowing up with food i was here five
years ago and had jeff on on triple d
and i went back and i thought well you
know i'll go back to some of the old
places whatever
it changed not changed it grew
exponentially so
uh houston's a great city i mean i
listen every time i go back to a city
i'm coming up your way by the way this
is when glenn you keep saying this no no
i knew you were going to say that so i
have a bunch of our president of food
network lives up in your area
my agent jason hodus and jeff google
live up in that area i said okay
listen i've been saying it long enough
september october i'm coming up there
right before it gets really cold and too
cold for a california dude it's gonna
happen we will talk about this
okay um toughest food to cook
to get right
one of the foods that's beat up the
worst is just flat out
chicken breasts you know it it gets that
that's i mean that's kind of the simple
one but i see people
overcook it all the time it becomes dry
becomes terrible steak
you know more times than not steak gets
uh gets a beer you know what it is
um things dry out faster than people
anticipate nobody likes there's two ways
of cooking
not two ways but it's either hot and
fast or low and slow
putting a fast sear on a steak and then
finishing in the oven or reverse searing
it or sous-viding it
where you really let the steak come up
to temperature before you put a crust on
it but
i see a lot of steaks get hammered
cooking it too much on one side not on
the other
but i think to answer the question
um wild game
file game is probably the most difficult
for people to cook
two reasons one it's super lean two
not a lot of not people don't have a lot
of experience with it
we uh have our meat fridays here and uh
i want to come for meat fry i want to be
there for me friday uh
you know we have tyler who cooks so i
don't know if we would have you
cook guy i i mean i'm out i'm not even
in yet
not yet not yet um
we have deviled eggs today i know you
don't like eggs
oh i can see it from the look yes yes
i'm not a deviled eggs guy but
should we have rethought this
well i personally don't feel that
deviled eggs falls into your meat friday
i mean i i think that there's a lot of
things that go into meat friday i mean
um well they sprinkled bacon on it and
they had it on the grill
so technically i mean i give points to
creativity there's no there's no
question about that but
i think that there's just so many other
fantastic options when you call
something
meat friday i mean that's kind of like
drum roll and music and fanfare
i mean i'm chateaubriand i'm i'm skirt
steak i'm
argentinian and i'm i'm you know some
big beef ribs well we have
pork on there we have we have pork but
we also
we also have broccoli with parmesan on
it
well i mean you know there's sometimes
just differences between the east coast
and the west coast maybe
on the east coast that's what when
you're rocking the meat friday no no
it's not
it's not no no that that our cameraman
who's health conscious
he made the suggestion we don't want it
but we'll do it
but you know maybe throw that into
thursday then dan
thursday that sounds like a really nice
wednesday or thursday menu but friday
we're going meat friday call me for meat
friday next time i'll send recipes
matter of fact i'll send you some
you know what you need is some big
tomahawk chops
i've got a bunch of moose meat i'll send
you some mousse meat make moose meat
meatballs
that'd be good okay but i want you to
come in and cook is that
is that rude though if i ask you to cook
it's it's not rude i take that it's not
only an invitation
but i it's the gauntlet has been put
down oh my god i don't know
can we call it if i make it there on a
wednesday can we call it meat friday we
can
click call it everyone around yeah we
can call it whatever you want
yeah hey by the way so a good buddy of
mine and i've mentioned a few times he
watches your show all the time
but someone had mentioned in a couple of
posts that i have my
dan patrick going in the background here
with all the bobble heads i
might my collection of goods they said i
did and i got you know the uh
macho man savage in the back i said i
take a good example i know when they get
when the show is going the right way you
got to have the
you got to have the uh the right you
know the right display going huh
look at what i've done no no i'm very
impressed because last time
we kind of mocked you when we were done
with you that it looked really lame like
you you cleaned up your shop there i
like that
you mocked me yeah we did well yeah i i
can't i'm almost
a couple more things and i'm not going
to be able to see you you are almost
behind
you're going to be wilson over the fence
in a second but when i have bobby flay
on man his background is awesome
just letting you know i mean he kills it
just just bring it i think
[Laughter]
well i imagine bobby you know what i
think could you take
bobby
to see the raiders beat the patriots no
like let's say
let's say ufc like you and bobby flay in
the octagon
oh i don't know i know bobby's pretty
tough bobby's uh
i'll tell you what bobby is an amazing
chef
an awesome restaurant uh a awesome
restaurant owner
great on tv i mean he's been doing this
thing a lot longer than me
i it would be i don't know who i put my
money on
okay but you can't bait me into these
dan i can't
yeah maybe if you uh get liquored up a
little bit then maybe i can that's
probably what happens
on our meet friday so it'll be on a
tuesday
um when we're up there shooting somebody
but you're going to come on triple d
with me i think we have talked about
this yes yeah i will and we're going to
go do i told you tell me some of your
favorite joints
you know when my agent pitches me and
says hey by the way there's this pizza
place up here i'm not saying you have to
go to it but it is my kids favorite and
i'm like
really why i imagine i'll be coming up
there shortly but we need to we haven't
shot up in your area in quite a while
but paulie
i got that show with giada that i'm
doing can i
i don't know if i'm gonna have time to
spend with with a guy
i would uh as your friend and uh
culinary consultant
uh i would absolutely take all the time
you need to go on johnny's show
any day by the way you got cigars now
that you're putting out you got
these flavor town cigars they're going
to be
oh this is flavortown kitchen this is
our uh this is my virtual this is the
ghost kit virtual restaurant but you got
a humidor over your left shoulder yeah
now there's a cut there's one there's
one over there too
oh okay yeah no so i'm getting ready uh
my buddy eric from espinoza cigars out
of miami we're getting ready to come out
with the flavortown guy fieri cigars so
probably november december is when we
should launch them but uh
knowing that you're a cigar guy i will
make sure that you uh that you have one
of the first boxes that come out but
we're gonna do a nice
we'll do a nice selection i'm a big
maduro guy torpedo
big ring gage but some nice lighter you
know
we'll have a good little selection of it
don't you have a sign back there that
says that renowned egg hater behind you
no but i think that you know since
everybody sends you something
no it's there i will fire up now
that doesn't say without not just this
flavor towel oh i can't get an egg hater
i'll get an egg hater just for you
oh no it's are you an egg lover
uh not a deviled eggs but i'm okay with
eggs i'm okay
i love your face yeah
yeah butterfly toast yeah i can do that
but i love
when you're doing diners drive-ins and
dives and somebody brings out an egg and
just the look on your face is awesome
well when i was on jimmy's show when i
was on jimmy fallon
he knows that i don't like eggs we were
having this little joke about it before
the show
and so of course as we're talking about
this the next thing i know middle show
he brings out a carton of eggs
and puts it on the counter you see i
hear you i don't like eggs and you know
what would it take for you to shoot
so chugging a couple raw eggs no problem
but cracking a raw egg over easy on top
of some toast
my wife will do it and just knows that
it drives me crazy it's just not you
know it's not my jam do i use eggs i
cook with eggs all the time that's it's
a necessity as a chef but
there's just certain ways in certain
times all right let me know when you
come up this way and then uh
i need your picks i need you to send me
some recommendations i know your your
whole
team yeah you're stable there of crazies
um come up with a list give me some
ideas i'd love to i'd love to get some
insight
okay all right that sounds great uh
thanks for joining us
and uh always great to talk to you thank
you that's uh that's guy fieri
celebrity chef host of dinosaur vincent